friends
friends man how many of us have don't
let me go well i will say that when
you're feeling down i had somebody say
to me what if you're feeling depressed
or you're feeling down and somebody say
that i respect say hey when was the last
time you practiced gratitude and i went
uh
and then he goes yeah when was the last
time you actually looked at what you
have that's amazing
and
and like
instead of looking at what you don't
have do you ever do that and you ever
think about that i was like oh [ __ ] man
i got to start doing that way more often
you don't do that i do but not not
enough
thanks tony robbins but i'm still sad
yeah yeah
but it is just re refocusing your eye it
is you know i could say i don't have
hair but then i could say look at how
strong my jaw is yeah
i'm saying bro you look outside my torso
is you know what i'm saying is that is
that what they're saying
they're saying how nothing hurts and i
can move so well you know what i mean
yeah is that i don't have hair
i'll tell you i was excited papa
chappelle came to the show oh yeah i'm
surprised you didn't know he didn't know
i was on the show oh he didn't know you
were there
no yeah
oh that's really cool he was excited
yeah you didn't tell him no
he knew he he didn't know until i
obviously walked out on stage that's
really cool man yeah yeah that's so
[ __ ] good
he's so supportive he's tough to keep a
secret too
did you call him out
oh yeah you did yeah come on now what'd
you say what'd you say what are you
looking for
a picture of your dad oh a picture of my
dad yeah that's us right there i love
your dad what did you say uh what did
you say though from the stage i was just
talking about his prison time
his time in 17 years you know man he
went through
it's really cool uh
i don't know i i think it's just dope
to have this relationship with him you
know it's just what'd you say 100 he's a
good guy yeah he's a good guy man i
don't know it's just one of those things
where
yeah like i could have ruled him out for
his past and all that stuff and
you know when i really think about it
man i don't know i i mean he was he was
so young when he started doing all that
stuff he was 12 when he started selling
uh drugs
so
i mean i was like well what's he like as
an adult as a person that's out of
prison as a person you know change yeah
because he had been out of prison by the
time we had reconnected i think he just
hit 10 years out of out of prison when i
finally
wow yeah he was like he had been out for
like 10 years i knew he was around but i
just knew it was that long yeah i knew
he was around his stuff and like
there's relatives of mine that um
you know pretty much got me linked
uh with him connected yeah yeah and i
just reached i just reached out to him i
said hey can i ask you some questions
and then sure and he was like yeah come
through he was excited dude he has good
energy too great energy he's just he's
just really happy that he's not in that
life yeah like it's like it's like a
he seems like relieved yeah huh yeah
he's just like super i got you know what
he was shocked about this girl's cool
too super cool you know what he was
shocked about he was like
in his most simple thing but like things
that we would never think about he was
like yo man he goes regular people [ __ ]
with me cause he's used to being such a
bad dude yeah and gangbanging in a drug
deal and like he was just like yo like
because uh people at the show like at
the end of the show because he stayed
and sat there and everybody saw him
exactly i know yeah and everybody was
saying hi to him but he was shocked
he was like yo regular people yeah [ __ ]
with me and just that simple thing right
there white person said hi yeah well
yeah like
it was so crazy and kyle tried to blow
his coat
i think when you go through [ __ ] like
that my buddy is going through some
something crazy crazy crazy crazy it's
crazy and then it's crazy crazy like
lost you know yeah and uh but he was out
he took the boat out he took his boat
out yeah and he was out in kind of ocean
not in the bay but the ocean and his
engine died
and he didn't have any way to get that
[ __ ] going and the waves were [ __ ]
kicking and he said man in most cases i
would have panicked my ass off and in
this case i was just like
i've [ __ ] been through way worse i've
gone through the flood this is [ __ ]
cakewalk yeah
and somebody found him really kind of
hung out because i'm not going to do a
guidebook i came along
someone came along yeah i wonder if
there was someone that
you know got to my dad like
i've never asked him that question
because usually
you know
when you go through so much crazy you
usually have that one person that
something that someone something changes
perspective or just like i don't know if
there was some person you need somebody
to believe in you one person just one
person especially in your formative
years to say you can do this or i you
know i see something in you yeah one
person oh i know exactly who mine was
my anger management teacher chip
children
sounds like a weather man there was
something he said to me he was the other
man too
and we're going to have a crazy good to
see you bella's me rain litter today
i see clouds over your head chappelle
you know he said this uh i don't know
there was there's
many many many things that he said but
he helped me understand how to take my
um
my power back
you know because through my anger and
all i was
releasing it like
yeah i didn't have any power yeah you
know what i mean because when when you
do that when you act that kind of way we
just lash out at people constantly
you're always trying to you're not in
control yeah and then he helped me
understand how to take it all
back you know because there was things
there was things in my life that i
couldn't accept
you know like obviously i've told this
story many times like
the you know just the relationship of my
stepfather growing up
yeah with my mom there's so many things
i just couldn't accept and i think
you know when i think about chip he was
the guy that really
you know
helped me like understand like yo man
your power is your power you know when
you when you lash out these people and
when you want to fight these people he
goes he goes it's not about them he goes
make it about you
make it all about your victim's
mentality yeah yeah he helped me without
even just saying like a victim and
talent he just helped me understand like
make it about you make like you take
control of it you tell you like
basically like you tell your story yeah
you tell your story because no one else
can do that for you no one else can
[ __ ] tell you tell your story because
you know it better than anybody else i
like the i what helped me a lot in like
just the idea that like if you look at
the the old stories like the old
testament or yeah any
everyone you know it either if they've
been through it they haven't everyone
you know has gone through some kind of
adversity something and a lot of times
it's not it's more than one thing yeah
yeah yeah and and you know and a lot of
times it's [ __ ] bad man and a lot of
people can handle it a lot of people
like alexander solzhenitsyn he wrote a
book called the gulag archipelago he was
in stalin's prison camps the gulag where
they would let you they would like it
was so bad they they wouldn't let you
sleep for more than four hours and their
guard would watch you no yeah yeah and
you would sleep you'd be freezing and
they'd have you you can only bring the
yeah oh yeah and you can only bring the
um sheet up to your nipples you couldn't
go past that what the [ __ ] it was the
worst that was like how they treated
them oh yeah it was that a lot of people
didn't of course didn't survive you
would starve all the stars but
solzhenitsyn
said what was amazing was that they the
people that that held their dignity that
held their [ __ ] together
because remember when he wrote the gulag
archipelago people credit that
particular you should read that because
you're into world war ii and yeah well
that book was was incredibly influential
and in fact is considered one of the
books that helped bring down the soviet
union that that that shattered the
illusion that communism
in in that when you when you enforce
when you when you have a leader that
forces equality across the board no
matter what yep you have to you have to
keep people that are different people
that are better people that work harder
that are more in you know industrious
you have to keep them down because
they're going to find ways to make more
money so then you have to say well if
you make more money that's theft you're
stealing from the state you're stealing
from the people they said there's no
individual the individual is very very
the individual is below the state and
that's the great evil yeah there's no
individual so his book really changed
that but he this [ __ ] said what
what changed his life
he was an atheist he was not a religious
person
was that the people with the most
dignity in the worst circumstances that
wouldn't compromise
that would not [ __ ] compromise or do
what they were told and died for it were
the really religious ones because they
were like i'm i'm suffering but watch
this
this one guy says something to the fact
i'm going to suffer
better than anybody you've ever seen
really i'm going to [ __ ] suffer so
well that even the guards were like dude
this [ __ ]
sometimes that's all you have i mean he
froze to death
i read that book i read that book and i
this there's a chapter called the
interrogation
and they would say they'd be like if you
think
you can stand up to interrogation yeah
you've never been interrogated yeah and
they would they put your feet nice right
yeah and they'd start asking to make you
miserable yeah
and you're gonna break that's why
this is our special force they they
always break yeah and some guys be like
you put my feet nice [ __ ] you i'm still
not going to talk and they go that's
cool here's the problem your daughter's
a dancer right your 11 year old daughter
is a dancer oh [ __ ] she's in the other
room and her feet are nice too
oh yeah now do you want to talk that's
how they [ __ ] do it they're going to
fix it you're going to [ __ ] sing
yeah but when you're delirious like it's
only a amount of like that's why they go
dude you don't have to do this like
you're trust me we're going to break you
yeah yeah you can do it now we don't
have to do it
yeah don't mind doing it well no you're
actually chomping at me really easy
watch this here's what we're gonna do
i'm gonna what do you what do you want a
couple things do you want oh you want a
shower i'll give you a shower you want
to go to the bathroom no problem you can
go to the bathroom you want to eat yeah
please don't make me [ __ ] in the corner
no no you can cheat anywhere you want to
eat yeah i'd love that oh good i'll you
write down stuff here's the only thing
we do have to restrict
you
you you can't sleep is that cool yeah
now this is crazy i'll let you sleep for
two hours yeah two hours talk to me in
five days when you have to be in stress
positions or you have to stand up or we
wake you up every hour or that's what
this is before they put you in a box
they can you can't move oh yeah and then
they played loud music and like go ahead
and sleep dude yeah that's a like time
death metal throughout the entire night
yeah but you can't you can't but you
can't but you can't be like
no you can't sit or and you can't stand
so you have they put you in a box where
you're like that
it's a great time human beings are i'd
be like i'm ready i'm ready to talk
oh they bring the box they're like nah
man no no i'm not all right man all
right so this person
what names you need yeah what name pal
yeah you can find it i'm telling
everybody
i know my phone number's my heart
yeah but they can also just torture
somebody you love that way they can just
be like that's the cartoon they'll hang
it over your head you're getting enough
sleep and everything you're good good
just in the next cell yeah every time
you don't answer you're gonna punch your
kid in the face yeah you're gonna and
it's crazy that they
can get a hold of your [ __ ] family
that's what the state can do that's what
they do if you give the state too much
power
no but government's good we'll have a
good government i know but there are
people behind standing right behind the
good guy
that love power that are going to come
in and do whatever the [ __ ] they want
and keep the power you can create a
system that rewards the worst people
there are sociopaths in the world now i
i need some i need energy i need
digestion i need simplicity i need taste
dude i'm glad you said that because
today's fire in the kit is brought to
you by athletic greens tell me about the
health and wellness company
that makes comprehensive daily nutrition
really really yeah but i want a
multivitamin i want a prebiotic i want a
probiotic i want i want my greens my
fruits and i want it in one scoop can
you help me with that yeah dude one
scoop for your old mouth ag-1 contains
75 vitamins minerals and whole foods
full food source ingredients including a
multivitamin multi-mineral probiotics
green superfood blend it's delicious
dude eight ounces of water one scoop
you're off to the races daddy all right
okay all right fine yep join the
movement of athletes moms dads step dads
aunts uncles grandmas podcasts what if
i'm keto or paleo or vegan or dairy free
or gluten free what happens that doesn't
interfere with any of that man to make
it easy athletic greens is going to give
you immune supporting free one year
supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase you've got to visit
athletic greens.com fighter today again
simply visit athleticgreens.com fighter
to take control of your health and give
aj1 a try
oh man the nba playoffs means next level
excitement get in on the first round
action with draftkings sportsbook
an official sporting
partner of the nba this week new
customers can bet five dollars on any
team to win and get 150
in free bets instantly instantly
you win no matter what all draftking
sportsbook customers can also bet on nba
hoops with same game party same gay
parlays combine multiple bets from the
same game for a bigger payout the more
legs you add the more money you win i
suggest giving it to three plus each day
of the first round get a risk-free bet
up to ten dollars if your same game
parlay doesn't hit you're protected man
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now use promo code fighter bet
just five dollar ruse on any nba team to
win their game during the first round of
the playoffs and get 150 dollars in free
bets instantly that's promo code fighter
at draftking sportsbook an official
sports brand partner of the nba minimum
age and eligibility restrictions apply
see show notes for details see next page
for directions for disclaimer in the
world now your dad did bring a fire ass
hat a lot of people bring [ __ ] right to
the show yeah yeah yeah
so i was like thank you thank you
uh i've noticed on that
post
your dad brought a mitchell nest
throwback denver nuggets hat oh and on
the side it says thick boy yep it's my
favorite hat now yes and he's sure to
send this picture to your dad so he
knows i'm gonna send you to send your
dad oh no he watches yeah can i get a
little color on volkanowski now you you
apologize to me apparently apologize to
you on there because i think on uh
wait what happened we talked about him
by the way moving to the lightweight
yeah i got a lot of like people were
like dude what the [ __ ] is brennan
saying you don't know what you're
talking about they were so mad i go hey
it's we're just we don't know that for
anybody who like for anybody who sends
me these things thinking that he's being
disrespectful
we are very close and we [ __ ] with each
other don't worry i don't feel
disrespected
i promise i don't isn't it funny how
people stress out over there but they
don't know so they're just getting
married
before they're coming from a good place
yeah
or not they're also people that want
drama
like people thrive that's social media
in a nutshell so if i dm you yeah and go
man you and bren such good like you're
my oh cool thanks man like that doesn't
really matter yeah but if i go yeah hey
man when [ __ ] brian looked at brandon
you like that they literally like it's
like high school gotham yes yes and
that's fun for social media i didn't
even like i don't you're being funny
when you're like when you go you don't
know what you're talking about huh
that's like how we joke that's like
that's a joke like
like how long have you guys known each
other right yeah but that's how we like
we'll get oh
oh it's like that you know it's like one
time i got leaked yeah like if we get
upset or something right like somebody
have a little you know right and then
you'll get a and then like we'll get a
video
you'll get a video from him or me which
would be like oh hey who am i an hour
ago
you know but that's but
i was talking to volk about it but
he's bigger than i thought you know he's
definitely bigger than his [ __ ] legs
yeah he's not a small dude and he was
saying that he only trains with like 155
percent up yeah so he could do it yeah
you know
if he's the right fight he could do it
there's some fight you know but is there
anything in it for him is it something
he wants to do no he'd be down for like
if they gave him a title shot he'd be
down 100 he's down for it he's he's down
he said he would fight connor and i was
like well connor's never making 45. he's
like no i mean about 55. but i just want
that feather in my cap because he was
the king of 45 division yeah and i've
taken all the legends but him so i mean
about 55. there's a good story there a
very good story yeah but yeah he's great
i don't think connor would fight him
i do you do yeah 100
i think connor i mean the idea that kind
of wants to fight us men is a little bit
nutty but
yeah but kind of wants to fight oozman
the ufc is never going to do that no but
the ufc do
connor nate at 170 the the ufc do conor
uh volkanovsky at 55. i can see him
doing that
there's a story though
is
five four what do you say
he says he's five five but he's probably
five four five yeah
you know maybe five three very short i'm
leaning oh cause you're leaning on the
yeah
yeah i didn't want to [ __ ] be shaq in
the picture
yeah and the it wasn't a food truck it
was the el camino that the guy grew
that's great that's really that's pretty
good but he's a great guy yeah he's
great yeah management's great they're
modest and uh such a good guy
great athlete yeah has two daughters
he's a beast yeah super b hell of an
athlete that's the hat yeah that was his
background he has sent to your dad
who was his what's his gold medal winner
uh in australia for greco wrestling i
didn't know that he was young oh my god
you know the national scene but then he
uh he was a rugby player but not gold
medal olympics no no never olympian but
whatever the gold is in their you know
national thing he won gold uh a
competitor his whole life though in
rugby yeah oh wow he's 214 pounds you're
a pro right semi pro but he was the mvp
of the semi-pro league yeah he's yeah
but he's not playing against the giant
maurice no but he but he he was saying
though like
i was like i was like well you're the
original thick boy because you're 240
pounds he's like dude you and rogan
started that rumor first of all he's
like then people photoshopped my picture
online he's like that's 214 pounds dude
okay
240. yeah he's like most of the pictures
you see online are photoshopped oh it's
hilarious oh but he said he was 214 just
eating a ton yeah
he's been with his wife since high
school that's impressive how old is he
it's just 33 something oh
oh damn that's an actual picture of him
there though because he showed me that
he's like this one's real that's a lot
of them you see our photoshop he's like
i wasn't 240 pounds no
shredded yeah he's a great great dude
rugby is a different sport man
yeah they're a lot of characters yeah he
is a rough [ __ ] man
yeah he's a really good dude yeah so
wait when did he start training like at
22. okay yeah which is you know kind of
late to start in the game but he was
like you started training late too i'm
like yeah because of football when
you're playing rugby that's playing
football my guilty pleasure is to look
up yeah the all blacks they're haka yeah
see how thick some of those guys are
yeah
so what is like a good age to start like
when kids now are you know they're
starting young yeah yeah it's a really
weird question though because if kids
are striking they can get glass jaw
syndrome like if you if you're getting
taken a lot of punishment yeah you
wouldn't want to be sparring every now
and age that'd be a bad idea get them
wrestling wrestling yeah
but then kids are learning mma where
they but they you know with the
transition stuff like that like
they're special so not i almost think
specialists i know there's young kids
out there training mma but specialists
dominate the game they do don't they
just do like that great wrestlers yeah
you know who's that
specialist in you know kickboxing yes i
wonder why that is because it will the
show dominate people can't catch up and
then if with that work ethic and skill
set yes they learn wrestling in jiu
jitsu and really it's an anti-wrestling
jitsu and
it's tough to get them down then you're
forced to stand with a world-class
striker [ __ ] man i mean
yeah look at cejudo look at look at uh
yo romero those guys spent their whole
life wrestling but i do think also
tomorrow
yes
when you start striking i think what
happens is they spend so much time
watching the human body move they
understand like now they translate it to
touching your face with their hands okay
i don't know how but it's also the work
ethic too like the work ethic from
volkanovsky from his
rugby or wrestling days bringing that
over to mma it just so to your point so
if you don't want if they shouldn't
start striking learn how to strike as a
kid and when no they can learn to strike
they shouldn't be sparring you shouldn't
be sparring got it you know even with
boxers like they they
it's it's such a science yeah they start
young but they take them up slowly like
everything
not really there's young kids in boxing
they i mean they they they crack fight
you see it but yeah but they are i don't
know the answer to yes i don't know oh
it's kind of just
who knows that means you know boxing and
hard to tell boxing and wrestling and
controlling your body yeah
head and hips yeah volcanos he's a great
dude though but yeah i've rocked your
dad's hat on purpose yeah yeah
but i do love the hat i know he said i
did a bunch of terrible stuff but that
would you say i get a bunch of terrible
gifts oh yeah people know people
people people trying yeah they're just
fans they you know or they have their
own merch so i'm like yeah yeah i have
my own merch
yeah yeah people people want to give a
lot yeah he came through with that
yeah that was dope one of my favorites i
get a kick out of any tough guy fighters
i love it because if you say one thing
if you go if you just say not big enough
for that division or nah i wouldn't put
him
they're going to hear about it and it's
going to get under their skin no he was
great because he i told him about the
lightweight stuff and he's like no i get
your perspective hundred percent he said
i get why you say that and most time
you'd be right he's like but i only
trained with bigger guys yeah he's like
i was also my like my bone structure his
hands are huge are they huge hands he's
got long arms
his arm's on that line he's just his
huge hands in his bone structure he's
like remember i used to be over 200
pounds man yeah my body and tendons are
big and i'm strong yeah he's fair point
yeah he was cool with it
i guess i guess the korean zombie in
korean which i didn't know said
i realized today i'm never going to be
champion yeah i'm going to retire yeah
yeah
wow
yeah your boy retired
no i'm not retiring he's not like he
can't be he just realizes he's never
going to be champion
at this point
yeah that's the biggest thing
but yeah like the game just changes man
you see it all the time like the game
just moves on
so what he'll still just fight he's
still you know he's ranked number four
well he's maybe six not just because he
was a champion jumped down that much
still a huge name okay but you know they
just gotta be smart with who they pair
him up with because yeah these young
guys are [ __ ] animals man
animals five yeah how much longer moved
to five so wow arnold allen be a great
fight for him terrible fight for arnold
island's a [ __ ] monster josh emmett's
a monster
he gives a monster bryce mitchell korean
zombie be fun yeah dan ige
i think they fought but either way
there's some fun matchups for him if he
wants to continue to do it yeah he only
moved down in one spot
so wait is that the next fight for bulk
and
no he doesn't have uh maybe if he's at
45 probably uh
um hollywood's halloween trilogy cejudo
like i asked him about cejudo and he's
like i don't entertain it man because he
just got and he's right you know
i don't cover on my show because most of
my listeners definitely know hardcore's
know
so suhu hasn't been in order to find the
ufc you have to be in the drug destin
program the usada and if so let's say
well let's say i retired and i was like
oh i want to fight jon jones steep or
the winner of jon jon stipe in july 2nd
i'd have to enter the testing program
and you have to test
negative for six months before you can
get a fight so when cejudo goes
you know when max holly backed out so he
goes i'll do it it's not even viable
option because you they they six months
no there's not and like i saw a headline
dan came out today it was like so who
does retired man we're not even
entertaining him versus volkanovsky
right
and then he wants more money dana's not
even entertaining because
he has to wait six months b they don't
want to pay him what he thinks he's
worth
because they don't think they can make
their money
they have the numbers
trust me if he was a was pulling the
numbers the fight would happen
do you think people would want that
fight though
you guys like me i mean
hardcore fans would but the ufc is going
well here's the numbers you bring and
then this is how much you want no
we'll we'll make more money him versus
max and verse connor him verse you know
and certain whoever still understands
rodriguez beats brian ortega you got
there you know so they're like we'll
just do that so they're not going to
play well
that's interesting yeah but folks such a
good dude
great guy
made for this game too made for the game
how about meatball went to coachella
this weekend how was that uh it was it
was good i went to
shrooms
yeah i took a little too much um
yeah so i started off with like a little
piece like we had the chocolate bar i
start off with a little piece didn't hit
me as strong as it would because it
takes a while right yeah and then like
it hit me a little not as hard as i
thought it would so i
took more and i kept taking more as the
night went on
and um let's just say i thought like i
saw into a different dimension
and i couldn't feel my legs at one point
and i was just like really really uh
high on shrooms which was unreal
yeah but uh
yeah did you come to a new understanding
yeah you did what was the understanding
um what do you mean new understanding in
other words you would you have a life
changing trip yeah did you make some
decisions
uh
yeah not to be as hyper critical about
myself and like that no one like i'm
always like very conscious about what
other people think of me and then like i
would just like because i was tripping
balls and i was like oh my god all these
people are gonna look at me and see i'm
tripping balls and everything
and like judge me for it and then i saw
a girl sitting by her porta potty having
a terrible trip just sitting in the
corner going like this and then that's
where i realized
who no one's like no one is giving her
attention like no one cares what about
other people they don't care about you
they are too busy worrying about
themselves so yeah the world's not
thinking about it yeah exactly we all
think they are you're a footnote in
everybody else's life yeah you're young
i guess that you go to coachella and do
shrooms and [ __ ] and that's the drug of
choice out there yeah
i thought it was like everyone's holly
uh
is that your scene coachella oh did you
go to cat weren't you gonna go no i got
offered uh to buy artists pass tickets
which sound really fun but the markup
was insane it's originally 1600 for
artist pass tickets if you know someone
uh but i
found someone who was selling it for
four grand i could not justify that [ __ ]
yeah that's a lot with ours what do you
what did it include all right
are passes that you can't actually buy
it's not available to the public you
have to know somebody who works with
coachella the actual event what does it
include but you're basically in the area
where all the performers are so you
can't buy a pass to there so like that's
where all like the weekend stays in the
artist area billy eyelashes my thing but
what are you gonna do like it's really
just like if you want to go there you're
closer to the stage where you're able to
see the concert yeah yeah you get to sit
and that would be worth it to get close
to the stage yeah general admission
you're in the sun in the desert
you know you know you're in the same
area
yeah if you're if you do general
admission you got to do vip and up in
order to get any shaded scenes kids are
passing out and [ __ ] yeah passing out
yeah never been my thing too many people
two-pack you love that [ __ ] oh my gosh
you love the porta-potties and a lot of
the crowds
you should go there
i can see you going there with no shirt
on just walking around bumping see i
like music festivals but the only way i
could do it is if i had like an artist's
pass otherwise
i would have no desire no i didn't
generally mention one year in it my
opinion wasn't i didn't like the music
festival vibe enough to do that yeah
i've been spoiled because i've gone to
festivals music festivals where i've had
like all access to
you know
everything so there's no i won't do it
anymore i'm sure it's fun for those
young kids when they're in the general
population just it's love it's love
younger audiences
[Music]
yeah
i mean you can go at any age to
coachella but it's definitely an older
crowd now it used to be a little more
family friendly
yeah that's what i'm saying yeah yeah
wait you're saying it's a younger crowd
now uh before it coachella used to be
kind of family friendly because you can
be any age like people will bring like
two-year-olds to coachella as a music
festival whereas now it's a little more
like we're here to party not necessarily
like just to listen to music yeah yeah
like younger party guys
i'd feel weird going at my at my age i'd
feel i got
these like tech guys they have a lot of
money and they go listen
because uh we want to include you in in
our coachella trip it's 10 grand uh we
bring rvs and we make a circle we hire a
sushi chef
and another chef and we and look we have
showers i'm like well that's so
exclusionary like it's kind of beats the
whole point the whole point like we rope
it off and we just have i'm like yeah
i'll just go to a hotel i want you to do
some kind of mingling is that to show
everybody around you that you have more
money
but they're tech guys you know
i bet they're so fun ah a blast a real
hoot have you guys ever been to a music
festival
no
maybe i've noticed but you did security
dc once i did security yeah before
but just at a venue it wasn't amazing oh
okay i did a security rave
if i was going to music festival as a
young guy i was it was like you all
you're thinking about is hot shitty
chicks yeah yeah you know you're like
all right maybe i have sex in a van with
some hot hippie
you know
i'll be on ecstasy christian did you
meet any young ladies high on shrooms um
honestly i was way too high to like
really talk to anyone besides my group
like that's how much it was
um i just really couldn't talk i was
just there for the ride like the
experience and
i just wanted to go just to see what it
was like now that i know what it's like
and what to expect now i'm gonna go
sober not as so uh not sober but not as
[ __ ] up as next year did you hear any
what were the musical acts you
you were vibing too billy alice was the
headliner and she ended her set going
sorry i'm not beyonce i shouldn't be
headlining this [ __ ]
it's hilarious yeah that's crazy i love
her even more she's great uh neon was
more like edm which i'm not too familiar
with like they played so much old songs
like they played 50 cent with an edm's
twist like there were no i don't
remember any
the only dj oh it's like the after party
right yeah
the only dj i remember was griffin and
he was at the rolling stone party
earlier but that's the only person i do
you have any desire to go chin
no no it's huge right yeah massive yeah
about stage country festivals but even
then it's just too long it's too many
yeah we so we stayed like 20 minutes we
stayed in palm springs downtown
palm springs and the festival was in
thermal it's like a 20 minute uber 30
minute uber
not bad
so like we just stayed down there and
then ubered back and forth
who were these friends you went with um
i went with uh my brother's manager
and uh like who that who's is
so can i see a panoramic view of
coachella do they have restaurants
not at the place no food trucks um i
think so you have to bring your own food
or what look they i don't know what
coachella neon carnival was like a late
like it didn't start until food trucks
yeah [ __ ] it was like 11 at night
that's in the middle of the [ __ ]
nowhere
yesterday yeah it went from 11 at night
till four in the morning
you stayed up the whole time i stayed
till like 3 40 and then dipped yeah well
that day and look at that yeah yeah
that's coachella
that's so crazy
wow actually when i was at your age i
would do the same yeah i'm like i'm it's
once a year like i'd rather get
everything out like experience
everything 23 you should 23 yeah fun
yeah it was definitely one of the best
experiences i've ever yeah
then how aggressive does that look now
just not for me man yeah yeah
i mean that is though i'm definitely
back next year
this is the guy just on the left
on the left
that guy in the left needs the speech
you gave when he kicked this show off
that's right my man gratitude bro he's
no gratitude because he's in love with
the girl in the middle and he can't get
him no he doesn't know them you think
that you think that i i think that's the
case brian i don't think he knows them i
mean that's probably me i'm in love with
her but i can't get her
yeah so strange yeah yeah coachella's a
people love you know my mother is one of
those people who loves a parade loves a
crowd i i'm just i always think that
something's going to happen
yeah me too yeah and there's like four
mass shootings this past weekend they
sure were sad dude they sure were they
had good security there yeah but do they
have like got do they they've been sick
people can bring guns there if they want
right no no no no no
yeah right
they can bring [ __ ]
how they can't bring a gun to any
concert in america no i mean no they
have an outdoor thing that looks so big
and hard to control one way to get in
yeah there's only one way to get in they
all have detectors yeah and they have
their the sheriff's department like
posted out that at that entrance they
had like security walking around at all
times you have to empty out your pockets
before you go in all this [ __ ] yeah
no weapons yeah i'm usually the same
with you guys like i don't like massive
areas with big groups of people but i
felt
safe there yeah safe issues
that's also part of it yeah
so you took a lot huh i took a lot i i
told the guy who was who's walking in
front of me i was like i feel like a
ghost i don't feel any part of my body
like i couldn't feel anything from my
neck down how long was the trip
till four am like yeah i took i took it
what time did you take it eleven i took
but i can't get 11. i kept taking some
throughout the night because it was a
chocolate bar so like i'd be just
hanging out and then like i'd reach in
my pocketbook ooh candy and i just it'll
keep you honest five hours be honest
keep it honest and no one in the group
met any ladies yeah yeah you guys yeah
you went up there just it was like a
boys trip sure
it was a lot of it was a lot of uh first
people's time yeah
it said it was a boy's trip you guys
want to go to the desert each room just
[ __ ] rock out together
that's quick but that's 21. or whatever
you want
23. young guy 23. hey guys i found
cialis in my pocket man it's 4am
christian it's just the three of us
yeah hey bro got it man you don't want
gonna do man
to go to work i can't feel anything from
the neck down
how about it i don't need my poppers
go to town nah next year i'm going to
train me jeff
coachella has another weekend you you go
on next weekend i'm not going to
coachella now i'm going to farmer jim in
the i heard the third weekend
oh they they do it back-to-back weekend
yeah three i think right no they just do
two two back-to-back weekends um it's
always that so i think next year i'm
gonna go and i'm gonna
actually try wow
actually try
talk to people not be too high yeah
yeah that edm music would drive me crazy
though yeah i'm not a fan of it it'd be
tough on the tough on the ears you know
but you're supposed to be high yeah
yeah i mean if you're on ecstasy it's
the best right
i didn't try i wish i had access so yeah
what did the music feel like on shrooms
i just feel like one with it like i feel
like it like i literally felt like one
way look at them bouncing right now
like waves was like oh yeah i like
remember looking up and just seeing like
the stage looked i was front row the
stage looked like it was like a mile
away because of the lights yeah and then
the vibrant colors yeah big friend on
the right must have been a real
hindrance in the front row there
no no he was vibing he was crushing it
yeah he's is he 40 or 50.
yeah why is he so old
how old is that christian the guy with
the glasses
dude i find it strange you guys check
out the ladies
hey he goes on a date a week
a week he goes well yeah he's a big old
burly guy he's uh because he's a
sweetheart he's a teacher okay he's 32
years old he looks a lot older than he
is maybe i don't know i just said she's
the will sass okay that's the end yeah
i'm like dude look at this cat that's a
big guy in here
now who is the magician in to your
right there in the middle yeah uh that's
my friend pezza he plays hockey with us
he's from rhode island he lives out in
california i like that cheetah print
he's working
him and this other guy earl who was
there they uh he showed up in the cheer
print and then this other guy who came
with us showed up in the exact same
shirt oh yeah
i thought it was hysterical
all right well i like it yeah yeah
i mean you can get wild too with your
outfits there you guys stayed pretty
conservative but well yeah you got you
got a couple
shirts cheeks out the back sure nah i
was absolutely yeah yeah this is pretty
cool
were there any like sexy girls and sexy
outfits that coachella oh yeah chin look
that up that's what i'm saying because
don't they dress like kind of wild wild
yeah i want to see that or they're like
showing like these girls like bodies
yeah i saw like a bunch of like ass uh
girls and cowgirl outfits with us with
chaps really really i'm sorry you didn't
say you say anything to the meatball i
didn't even feel like i was on planet
earth i had no idea where i was yeah
that's true that's uh that's uh yeah
they've got some don't you find you nice
yeah coachella gives you a weekend and
just really [ __ ] it out yeah
there you go it's like halloween
get away with whatever one halloween you
know yep and they have rides there too
yeah they have like uh ferris wheel
swings this weird thing like we that
thing like where you go in the cage and
then it like flips you around oh
you got to wear like electric green look
that's a cool lookout let's see that
it's just a thong i really appreciate
that come on chin well it's hot out
oh
my my choice my booty my choice i
appreciate it right girl
i agree and nothing is low
i've never seen a girl sag or thong yeah
short crack
well good for you christian yeah yeah it
was a lot of fun what'd you do this
weekend jen he was in the great lakes
yeah great oh how'd it go it was awesome
oh wait is it cold you wanted to trip
the rv
[Laughter]
wait i want that tattoo badly well went
away
wait did they announce this fight chin
scroll down
opening odds potential ooh mine's 200
seriously um july 2nd where's your
spreader i'll show you right now
this
so there's the van
next three days that looks so dope
that's cool check it out
next three days
it's called rose the revel
that's great it's a bench
did you catch fish oh yeah a little tid
how many how many fish hey look at you
living on an orange and soda
there's truly's in there too we will not
be using i doubt we will yeah we didn't
use it you showed us this no one use
bathroom no bedroom there's a bed oh
oh okay
that's where all the love making yeah
there's our fish king size [ __ ] oh damn
it just me and joba me my girl we caught
19 walleyes
up there
it's a dad and son
the captain and his first mate and your
charter you'll uh you'll eat all those
fish yeah all right that's that's what
sucks so we couldn't bring them back
home
so we took a bath i mean i didn't want
to go through shipping and all that
stuff so yeah it's a [ __ ] for that we
gave some to uh the person we rented the
van to and we gave the rest to these
guys and they're frozen
yeah and the meat is so good walleye
it's like one of the best fish i've ever
had
oh you you cook some of it though you
did at the campsite yeah oh yeah you do
a sashimi style or we don't know you
can't do that with fresh water oh you
can't no you could say that yeah
something about the bacteria or
something like that you get sick from
really yeah
ocean fish
sushi are you you good at cooking fish
like that i think i'm pretty good yeah
kills enough of them yeah better be good
at it yeah damn you guys killed a ton of
fish 19. you murdered you can't tell how
big they are but they're huge are they
no you can tell they look pretty big
especially the one in the middle has the
gut yeah this one but that sucks though
because they're pre-spawn yeah son of a
[ __ ] i know
wow
it was a good little birthday phrase
yeah i had a good time and what you guys
were there three days three days
thursday friday and saturday okay
wait it came out sunday i wasn't driving
that sprinter van was it nice
it was actually a lot easier than i
thought because we've driven i've driven
rv before and it's just it's it it's
anxiety it's so big yeah yeah you think
you're gonna like crashing everyone so
this is kind of like narrow-ish
it's really high so the win the win hit
you have to be like this that's what
comics use them for tour buses yeah he's
doing that and you could stand up in him
which is the best thing like i could
actually stand up and not hit my head oh
wow yeah
damn that's nice look at you living that
life dog i know dude all right that's
all buddy
thanks dude
well happy birthday glad you had a good
birthday thanks bro hey b
can we take a break let's take a break
first we'll get right back to the fight
we'll get right back we'll get right
back but dude listen if you want to pay
off your student loans faster you need
to listen right now earnest let's talk
student debt you could potentially save
thousands with refinancing that's what
we're trying federal student loan
payments are on hold but with the rates
this low now is a good time to refinance
i would say the best time we've earned
money dude ernest was voted best student
loan refinancing overall by nerd wallet
ernest has some of the lowest rates
flexible payments and in-house team
ready to help you you can also change
your interest rate get a lower monthly
payment and you never pay fees not even
late fees nutsos yeah you can refinance
you can reduce your loan term save money
or combine multiple loans into a simple
monthly payment dude if you've got any
questions you can even talk to a real
life human i'm live here this is for
help a real genuine human being that's
correct with earnest it only takes two
minutes to see what your new rate could
be and there's no credit impact and
right now ernest is offering the firing
kid listeners and viewers a hundred
dollar cash bonus refinance your student
debt at earnest.com fighter available in
all states once again you get 100
buckaroos when you visit earnest.com
fighter to refinance your student loan
hit em b hit them with that
visit earnest.com fighter for more
details not available in all states
terms and conditions apply or earn a
student loan reimbunse made by earnest
operations llc nmls 120 49 17 california
financing law license number get this
this is exciting 605
4788 address i know you've been waiting
get your pens out 535 mission street san
francisco california 94 105. visit
earns.com
licenses plural
for a list of licenses earnest.com
fighter
so this was making rounds where a
twitter account
said that there was a rumor going around
that asap rocky and rihanna had broken
up because asap rocky had cheated on her
with the woman who designed the fenty
footwear line it was all fake and it
turns out two days later that guy
retracted said i heard the story from
people who
gave me bad information and i take it
back people are speculating my phone was
social media why the [ __ ]
would this go viral basically but some
guy on twitter right that's
crazy okay he's just a random dude just
a random dude and then again and then he
goes
this is social media nutshell like again
the gossip the negativity yeah he
cheated on rihanna and he's like what
yeah
and it's insane i feel so bad for the
woman that they accused of cheating with
asap rocky because they outed her name
on there when she didn't do anything at
all and she got a swarm of hate she's a
shoe designer yeah she's her shoe
designer and her last post happened to
be a photo of rihanna pregnant and she
got so much hate for it she went on to
social media and said
what the [ __ ] going on it was like i
didn't want to say anything about this
because it's fake and i didn't want to
address a fake rumor about me but
apparently i have to because i'm getting
death threats she's getting dead yeah
brianna's pretty popular yeah very very
popular mm-hmm but yeah she's been
you shouldn't have to do music she's
like [ __ ] this music game jesus what
else you got yeah i'd love to see you
live
so kyrie irving
had a game against the celtics he had a
good game and he had a really good game
but
what's going viral were the video clips
of him flipping off the
crowd in boston i guess he made a shot
this is the clip he makes the shot and
then he runs off and flips off the crowd
he then proceeds to make the little like
cry cry baby face
yeah he had a good game they should i
wish they would have so they were trying
to give him backlash for doing that uh
yes he was saying that it's in like the
spirit of sports you kind of like you
you get that type of [ __ ] and then you
give it back to the crowd that's just
what it is no he had a great uh comment
though he was saying in the post game uh
interview they're like man you were
pretty aggressive with the boston fans
remember i used to play for boston and
then he laughed and when he left his
kind of weird way he left so they have a
lot of animosity towards him so when he
comes there with brooklyn and they're
you know calling him [ __ ] and [ __ ] and
he goes because i know we're supposed to
be all humble and stuff like these this
the playoffs though man he's like i mean
kill him up yeah he's like i'm not gonna
entertain this yeah i don't see nothing
wrong with him yeah he goes i don't know
you know if people won't talk [ __ ] and i
give it back now i'm a bad guy yeah let
me see what he says here
[Music]
somebody's gonna call me out of my name
i'm gonna look at them straight in the
eye and see if they really bout it
most of the time they're not probably
what's that hat i don't know
pretty dope though yeah no i respect
that yeah how could you not yeah it's
just like wait oh it's awesome
flip people off for talking [ __ ] to him
he had a great he had a great game too
he's a monster he's a monster you see
that like yeah as i was watching i was
thinking to myself like how hard it is
to be him like i mean as far as to be
that good like you know how good he is
like in comparison to all the people out
there marry he missed most the season
too because he refused to get the
vaccination shot so he's always
controversial yeah but he stands by what
he means willing to pay the price i got
no problem with that if you're willing
to pay the price it's like ali nobody
ever talks ali ali [ __ ] dedicated i
mean sacrificed six years in his prime
yeah uh because he wouldn't go to
vietnam
years dude
what moral courage god damn what else
some of those twitter edits were funny
too they used that uh video of him
flipping off the crowd where it says fan
kyrie the earth isn't flat and then
kyrie flipping them off
yeah he has some weird beliefs for sure
yeah that's all right
so this is a follow-up from an older
story that we talked about recently a
south carolina man who is on death row
actively chose
to have the firing squad go off on him
as his way out now the south carolina
has firing squad available yeah because
they they the choice was electric chair
firing squad
firing squad all day
long well this is what we're talking
about last time where they just go out
yeah yeah both shots
yeah
both are not a good time but no but but
fire squad is you're done you're just
like boom you just do what this this is
what happens goose
you gotta put on your head and you're
just
gangster i would ask for no hood
for no hood yeah but
they won't let you because the shooters
don't want to see your face a lot of
times
they have to kind of dehumanize you a
little bit yeah and some of them have a
blank in there so
not all real bullets so then they don't
have the the guilt of knowing whether
they don't know who did it you know i
mean but also
yeah it's dark
this is so [ __ ] dark
this is another update to the elon musk
twitter situation i guess he had pro he
had given
twitter a huge offer it was what 41
48 40 something like 41 billion dollars
48. the 41.2 billion billion dollars to
buy twitter outright and the board
actually went and blocked and they
changed the rules about him being able
to buy it with how many how much stocks
he owns currently
it's just basically their way of saying
no we don't want elon musk
but if you're a shareholder in that in
that in twitter like a big shareholder
you're in it for money yeah if you get a
whatever 48 million dollar billion
dollar offer offer and the company turns
it down no you can the shareholder's
gonna sue them like no we could have
sold this [ __ ] thing yeah everybody
makes so much more money 100 and now
you're declining it that's not what we
signed up for that's right so the the
shareholders can sue them yeah will that
happen
um
it's going to get messy no matter what a
new shareholder rights plan black united
marx
huh
it's where they can just change the
rules while it's trying to be acquired
yeah how weird is that i guess when that
happens it's called the poison pill and
it was not 41 billion he offered 43
billion as a bid
and they're in the twitter's worth what
how much 30 30.
something yeah
still if you're still yeah
you're still evaluating is offering you
gotta you know you gotta do what's best
for the company now that is what would
be best
yeah but that he can that'll that plan
is only for a year
it's gonna get messy
what are sketching
that's right here they have to put it to
a shareholder vote like you said i think
yeah yeah
unless they change the rules
but if you're
i mean i get dying on a hill that you
believe in that and you don't believe in
freedom of speech which is hilarious but
if you're an investor yeah give me my
[ __ ] money dude i don't care who runs
this thing right it's not like jack
dorsey's awesome you know he's a
psychopath what else you got
this woman from alaska she was recording
something for her tick tock it's called
the dirty explorer i guess when she's a
dirty explorer the dirty explorer
probably when she's not you know jogging
or hiking in nature or whatever and then
she noticed that there was this crazy
rock slide and she recorded it and then
she actually saved someone's life a car
that was coming through about to go to
the same direction she kept running
towards it you can see everything here
direction where the rock
[Applause]
see how loud that is
what are the chances i know
[ __ ] me
oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
wow stop stop stop
stop
stop
stop your car
you see all that
debris right there
whoa god it's loud mm-hmm it's weird she
had the what's the [ __ ]
it was a rock slide
literally kill me 30 seconds [ __ ]
killed
let me think about that and screaming
down the road just so you know on the
beach
so yeah she basically saved that dude's
life wow that's pretty cool they said
there's a second rock slide but then
there's car sized boulders that were
coming yes brian no no no what brian
what brian
come on no no no
i want to know brian it's good i'm i'm
proud of her no brian she did the right
thing
no it's just like a lot of times people
go that was you save me from certain
death oh would you have kept driving
into the landslide
you would have saw it though you know
you would have stopped you heard the guy
but i appreciate a lot of rocks i do
appreciate that
yeah it's not even like oh my god the
rocks are coming yeah
yeah
yep she did say that yeah maybe yeah i
just saw the video and i would i i
there's a stretch there where he would
have enough time
brian if i had done that i wouldn't have
videotaped it and i would have come here
with that
story yeah and people would have been
like
i've told this story before but she
didn't you think it was one of the
tickets [ __ ] what's that yeah if she
didn't videotape we've been like all
right cool
i was credited for saving someone's life
my friend we got caught in rapids and
he was getting pulled and i i had a
branch and i pulled him over and
apparently i
saved his life and his parents said
thank you for saving my son's life and i
was like you're welcome they were like
you're a hero no i wasn't i went like
this
i got you
you see the stretch of road though
yeah i mean the video is not that great
either no no but i could see that no no
listen it's let me see it's just the the
guy
yeah
one more time i mean what are the
chances of this [ __ ] happening
i think
those landslides are violent
giants
yeah
and she's way out of the way right
like not even close
like this you could just stay right
there
nothing would happen
nothing happened
here you go
so next time
yeah it's
definitely so next time it's a rock
slide and you see brandon or brian just
keep walking just keep on just keep
walking they got it yeah keep on they're
fine all right well yeah good for her
though yeah yeah
it's cool footage
what's the sound happening the sound
ryan doesn't right he's not down with it
he's not real life is just never as as
awesome
as as i always say to conspiracy
theorists i'm always like man you guys
give the government so much credit to be
able to organize it's just usually
secret the truth is a lot probably a lot
less sexy than you think it might just
be that people are just inept
yeah
but
i just grew up with a mother i grew up
with a mother who
loved to be like you know i could have
been we could have been killed if i
hadn't pulled over nope you were going
30 miles even close mom
not even close
even if it happened we wouldn't have
been we wouldn't have died
when don't you get you a little update
with kane
so the guy that
obviously is allegedly the molester his
defense attorney saying that he's
innocent and they're going to prove it
somehow i mean what else is that
so that's just the newest thing that
happened and then you see kane in the
courthouse
signing i love you to his family it's
the first time i guess he saw them jesus
christ
i mean
who would have thought man this is
insane yeah
yeah so he's looking at 20 years to life
but if that molester gets
convicted it was like six years or
something like that ooh hopefully he's
interesting
he's in the same prison
yeah that wouldn't
that's terrible all right what else you
got yeah
let's go to
here
so mega dean stalin's megan v stallion's
coachella performance it was streamed in
china
through an app
and that app had a sensor on it
and
they're trying to get all the bad stuff
but it was they didn't know what to do
so you see the black bar just kind of
running like crazy and then i ended up
not covering anything because they're
just like showing this black bar
[Music]
it's all sir there's too many asses
freaking out here
these all uh i love it
that's she's such a baddie i know
i love it yeah she's great
maybe just don't air it china i mean it
was like illegally streaming
how richard gere in 1995 i don't
remember when he talked about
no he talked about tibet and the dalai
lama and how china was doing essentially
committing all these crimes and he has
never been in a big movie since never
because china was like well
he's not going to be in the we're not
going to distribute that movie and
whenever you talk foreign distribution
yeah you're not you're not getting in
the movie unless they can sell it
overseas it ain't happening so china
went uh he's out he's out so richard
he's a big [ __ ] movie star huge movie
still huge yeah has not been
he's not been in one marvel movie not
one never and he never will be because
china's like he's probably 89. i told
you when i did the movie in hell it was
trying to advertise that movie i did in
china yeah they redid the well they said
they said you're not allowed to
there was a whole scene where i had to
chase a guy all through beijing
and through old beijing and i and i was
i was an american cop and i was going to
catch this chinese national
and they said there's not a shot you're
going to have an american running
through old beijing catching
one of our citizens and putting them on
the ground
we had to rewrite the whole script
my shoot went from being i don't know
three weeks to four days i remember that
really yeah [ __ ] well there's a reason
why john cena learned [ __ ] mandarin
and apologize yeah because what they
said to him is they go it'll be the end
of your career yeah um
if you think about it in that context
somebody said i'd be speaking chinese
too
dude i love the chinese what the hell i
did not mean i don't blame them
i mean yeah it'd be the end of your
career
like we will never be able to finance a
movie with you in it because china will
not accept it that is
billions of dollars
especially as an action yeah if you're
like you know
comedy romantic or whatever romantic
comedy actor you'd be all right money
talks yeah you when you look at it that
way i'm more sympathetic because i've
never been in that position no i get
john cena it's a [ __ ] move but i get
what you like your bottom dollar i mean
your career no your career no because
what you brought up last time you like
there's a lot of people he's probably
helping out as well oh my god you know
what i mean like so they're probably
like hey john like
do something i know a guy who's who's
really wealthy and he and he's really
paranoid of covet and i was making fun
of him a little bit he goes no no dude
dude hold on i have
like 2500 people that
rely on me and if i'm out or i get
really sick for 20 days it's a big
problem because you make all these and i
was like i get it that makes sense i
don't have no it's muscularity
it's like tom cruise who did who took a
year to say no to a movie that um my
buddy was making
and it was because when he says yes to a
movie it's literally a big deal yeah the
whole everybody makes money everybody
all right just one more it's just a
funny video
hold on one sec
oh boy hands go no i could have told you
this is already an issue
go go girl
get it
don't let go
oh
[ __ ]
why did she do a flip like that
because
how did that happen i don't know i just
saw this video was just so hilarious
that was an amazing [ __ ] flip she
landed safely i mean that's that's the
best outcome she could have yeah
that's the best outcome she might
it was such
ain't [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] hello that was a
good one
that's it that's it all right kids uh
look what we got here this wednesday
night we have
david lucas michael rapport giannis
papas
and a very special guest uh to me he's
top three goats of all time he's making
a uh a stop at the shop and friends this
wednesday night 8pm the show will sell
out so we get tickets that you listen to
this right now hollywood improv shop and
friends this wednesday night 8pm one
show only by the way and then saturday
is moon tower economy festival paramount
theater it's a big venue for your boy
come on out austin paramount theater in
austin texas moon tower comedy festival
one show only with a thick boy squad on
saturday night and then charlotte is may
5th through the 7th philly may 19th
through 21st
and the special drops april 28th
on thick boy
youtube uh i'll see you this weekend
back to florida kids thursdays
yeah the vasani comedy theater woo
las vegas about it wise guys comedy club
april 28th 29th 30th and then new
brunswick new jersey stress factory
may 5th and 7th and oh by the way dc
comedy loft may 12th the 14th um
and my special brea improv may 19th
two shows come soon boom may 6th to 7th
i'll be in san diego at mike drop comedy
club and then may 12th i'll be doing a
one-nighter
uh stand up live in phoenix and then
later this summer june 24th to 25th i'll
be in uh at comedy connection in uh
rhode island
and the food truck with basically an el
camino food truck with volkanovsky drops
on thursday on think boy youtube so
enjoy that kids oh we just dropped the
the mic stud little brows stand ovation
uh the first feature on the thick boy
album that dropped on 28th as well
that's available on itunes apple music
amazon spotify the music videos on thick
boy as with mike stud in the very
talented little brows the full album
drops on the 28th and you got freaking
jelly roll on there mike stud
bert kreischer crystalia
uh whom i missing chen chappelle eric
griffin
mark harley
it's great man but yeah all that drops
the 28th but the the first single is
available now on itunes or wherever you
listen to music all right kids that's it
also i just got this announcement they
just dropped uh all masking airports oh
they did federal federal district judge
in florida enter summary judgment
declaring uh
that's beautiful airline mass mandate
unlawful you're kidding vacates the cdc
mass mandate
so
it's been a [ __ ] two years yeah
so i i get to be i'm flying all the way
to oh that's so beautiful and that great
a great way to end the pod yeah but does
that let's all go get the new variant
let's go get them let's go get it